welcome back to drew's news this is your
show well savannah
it says here that you've got a news
story for us i sure do
drew it's a big one too there's a huge
mystery it's been absolutely stumping
experts
for decades and we decided it was time
to do a little digging of our own
so we got dateline's keith morrison on
the case oh my gosh
and he filed this report in today's drew
crime oh my gosh we've been talking
about take a look
if he would ever do something with us
hello and welcome to drew crime
mysteries
a true crime series dedicated to
mysteries surrounding people
named drew i'm keith morrison
people who know her say that drew
barrymore can
light up a room in fact she lights up
her room so much
it's a little suspicious drew
is too nice i mean who is that nice it
just like it started to concern me
she spends entire segments of her show
helping people with stain removal
that's not normal has anybody met
anybody with that much enthusiasm
about anything about everything she also
doesn't age
her skin is like like a baby's butt
yeah like a baby's booty yeah it's just
so hard to believe someone like her
really exists
and that's when we started to think what
if she doesn't
what if drew barrymore isn't real what
if drew barrymore doesn't exist i mean i
was married to her
i don't even know if she exists
yes her friends fear the worst
but drew barrymore did exist
or did she we started wondering like
maybe she's some type of hologram
or like collective hallucination
maybe she's just a bunch of kittens in a
human suit
i mean has anybody thought about that or
maybe
just maybe she did exist
but had been exposed to one too many
stain removal solutions
perfect skin perfect host
perfect attitude
yes drew barrymore seemed a little too
good to be true
so we put our investigative team to work
we obtained a little bit of drew
barrymore's dna
and what did we discover why it was
shocking
it confirmed not only does drew
barrymore exist
she's one of a kind
that's it for this edition of true crime
mysteries thank you for joining us
[Music]
joining us now is the man who finally
after decades cracked the case keith
oh morrison that was that was such a
tough one too though
the people we had to talk to the dirt we
had today
i cannot believe hello drew happy
birthday
thank you and i have all the things that
could have been said about me this was
so
tame and kind
well um we we left some of those things
in the cutting room before
understandably so keith was this one of
the
sweetest and most adorable mysteries
you've ever had to solve
undoubtedly the sweetest and most
adorable mystery
keith thank you so much for making
drew's day special it's so fun to have
you here
and i am happy i'm just i'm delighted to
be here i'm still pinching myself and
happy birthday drew
thank you so much thank you
you